muy buena noche bienvenidos a la crónica
de economía de france 24 dedicada en
esta oportunidad a conocer el escenario
que se vive en chile de cara a las
elecciones del próximo domingo nos
acompaña por supuesto jorge hurtado
jorge bueno como decía chile está a las
puertas de unas elecciones que se van a
ver de un ambiente muy polarizado verdad
que le espera la economía chilena bueno
los domingos los chilenos van a decidir
su futuro económico y las propuestas son
bastante amplias desde la creación de un
estado del bienestar basado en países
europeos hasta reducir el iva por
ejemplo gabriel boric de izquierda que
por mencionar alguno de los candidatos
sugiere en su plan a asegurar una
pensión mínima de 308 dólares así como
aumentar la cotización mensual desde el
actual 10% del salario al 18% con gran
parte del cargo al empleador otro de los
competidores es josé antonio kast que
apuesta por mantener el modelo
ultraliberal impuesto durante la
dictadura de augusto pinochet su plan de
gobierno busca disminuir la
participación del estado en la economía
así como reducir el impuesto al valor
agregado antes conversamos con
él bergoi en el es economista académico
e investigador chileno sobre que se
espera para la economía tras estas
elecciones y esto respondió
efectivamente el día las encuestas al
menos dicen que en segunda vuelta lo más
probable es que gane el candidato que
está más bien en la izquierda no en la
cnte izquierda pero en la izquierda
aunque él tiene un equipo técnico de
integrantes que muchos de ellos sí son
de centroizquierda yo los conozco varios
de ellos son incluso socialdemócrata
pero es una generación como te decía más
joven y lo que lo que va a ocurrir si él
es elegido el gabriel boric presidente
muy probablemente es que se va a generar
esta tensión entre por un lado lo que
piden los organismos internacionales lo
que típicamente es de la macroeconomía
es tan valorado que es la certeza la
estabilidad agregada que ayuda a la
inversión de largo plazo es tan
importante para el crecimiento sostenido
pero al mismo tiempo la necesidad de
hacer cambios profundos para como
decíamos mejorar las dimensiones
sociales en particular la distribución y
eso va a generar ruido va a generar
susto va a generar probablemente una
paralización no digo que completa pero
durante un tiempo en la inversión de
largo plazo y eso claro va a tener
efectos inmediatos en términos de crecer
menos pero la pregunta si vamos a salir
de esos fortalecidos esa es la gran
incógnita que hay hoy día jorge vamos a
hablar ahora de uno de los que fue los
temas centrales en la campaña en materia
económica no de cara a las elecciones
chilenas hablamos de los fondos de
pensión que sucede con eso bueno
santiago allí el sistema es privado y es
señalado por obtener grandes beneficios
y de entregar bajos montos a los
jubilados algo que ha motivado el retiro
de estos fondos ahora mismo se discute
un cuarto retiro que el senado rechazó
recientemente esto comentó a nuestro
invitado respecto a las pensiones
algunos políticos particularmente en el
congreso a portas de una elección han
decidido impulsar una serie de retiros
de los fondos de pensiones que lo único
que están haciendo es justamente reducir
la probabilidad de que podamos a esta
generación darle mejores pensiones hacia
adelante porque se tratase retirada se
utiliza hoy y eso que tuvo mucho sentido
el año pasado cuando estaba partiendo la
pandemia y por lo tanto el gobierno
tenía muchas dificultades de llegar
producto bien a la gente y que pudo ser
justificado en el primer retiro terminó
103 retiros e incluso una discusión de
un cuarto retiro diría que ha dejado
casi la mitad de la gente que está en el
sistema de pensiones sin saldo en sus
cuentas entonces en una línea por un
lado se entiende la necesidad de
reformar profundamente el sistema y
obviamente nuevamente uno piensa que
como en los países más exitosos con un
sistema más mixto con un sistema
personal y un sistema en el estado pero
al mismo tiempo se ha usado
lamentablemente esa discusión para
justificar en el contexto de la pandemia
retiro significativo que lo único que
van a hacer es disminuir las
posibilidades de que esta generación
tenga buenas pensiones en el futuro se
sacaron 50 mil millones de dólares y en
el caso de chile en imagínense ustedes
es más o menos del presupuesto un año
completo del estado así que los montos
que salieron fueron gigantesco igual que
recuperarlo en algún momento y eso ver
que hacerlo con más impuestos ahora
jorge una pregunta clave que surge en
este contexto que vos no vas a ayudar
por supuesto a responder es en qué
contexto económico se dan estas
elecciones bueno luego del consumo
motivado por el circulante inyectado en
la economía tras los retiros de los
fondos para el próximo año los datos no
son alentadores en el tercer trimestre
de 2020 la economía chilena se contrajo
un 9,1 por ciento interanual por la
pandemia cuando tenía las actividades
económicas semiparalizada aunque este
año el producto interno bruto creció un
17% se estima que el 2022 del pib
crecerá sólo entre el 1.5 y el 2.5 la
inflación dobla la proyección oficial
del banco central y la deuda pública
está en el 33 por ciento graciasjorge
por esta crónica dedicada al escenario
económico que vive chile a nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com sigan con nosotros
[Música]
y